[Music]
hello everyone i'm grandmaster
and this is grandmaster's choice
this time i'm going to show you my
most complex games versus daniel adobo
you might be wondering who is daniel
dubov
now if you haven't been following the
new chess meta
they've been new young and upcoming
grand masters who like playing their
brand of chess
their brand of chess that is a bit more
refreshing
a little bit more speculative a little
bit
more intuitive so for that i'm going to
show you
a couple of those games that i played
against him
in recent times online so
i'm going to start with this game and
you'll see
that his style is
more of explained as a chess maverick
and he's
not afraid to be one so let's get
started
so in this game i played one e4
e5 and you might be wondering what is
the big deal your opponent just played
e5
well duboff plays literally
everything he plays c5
he plays e6 plays c6 he plays e5 of
course
all of the moves are possible and it
really depends on his mode
so e5 knight c3 sort of an invitation
for the vienna 92 and
sort of i'm bouncing the ball
back into his chord knight ge2 is not
a very usual move
so i'm sort of giving an
own taste my favorite taste to the
position
sort of we're trying each other knight
c6
g3 bishop c5 bishop g2
but after a little bit of move ordering
we actually arrive at a classical vienna
position
with white losing the fight for the d4
square
but winning the battle of the d5
d6 d3
a5 and a5 is again
a different type of move any time you
check the database
what moves have been played it's usually
either
h6 taking away the bishop
g5 square stopping that pinning idea
or a6 now there is a flaw to h6
which a5 and a6 solves
and that is there is no knight a4
anymore because the bishop can hide on
a7
but again this is what i'm going to talk
about
while we look at these games that i
played against
daniel dubov he likes to go
into openings and ideas that are not
well trodden
and are very original this a5 move sort
of shows
he is ready for a fight like always
h3 and he even goes
further plays not just a5 but a4
and moves it down the board even
threatening to play a3
now if anything i felt if i let a3
happen
my knight will get a little bit unstable
with a charger upon having to move to b2
b3 so i'm going a3 myself i don't want
that to happen
knight d4 not only
putting a knight in the center but also
making sure i don't have d4 brakes
knight takes c4 i just want to eliminate
that strong knight
bishop takes d4 knight e2 i'm trying to
get rid of that bishop
bishop b6 so this
is a moment for us
to think for a minute so what would be
an
interesting way for white to continue
don't forget most of duboff's pieces
are lurking around my king side
so castling might prove to be somewhat
risky
it is probably playable but at the
moment
risky way of play so if you're not
castling
what type of other moves could we
consider here
was this game played on league chess
obviously you can go bishop e3
but bishop e3 would be
somewhat tepid and if you're playing
against daniel dubov
at least you want to spice it up so i'll
play g4
i did not want to go bishop e3
i want to start expanding
on the king side bishop e3 probably
is even but g4 is way more ambitious
now my opponent that is daniel dubo
realized oh
so you play it that way you do leave a
couple of squares a weekend
and embarks on a quite interesting
maneuver in fact a very strong one
knight d7 it's not just a move
it's a plan it's a plan either go
through c5 e6 and to f4 and d4
or go knight f8 knight g6 knight h4
and knight f4
and that that's actually kind of the fun
part
of this game called chess if it's not
a well-trodden path if it's not an
overanalyzed
berlin position there is still a lot of
play
left and these original ideas and
maneuvers
can be accomplished knight d7
knight g3 knight c5 now
if i'm just waiting around
dobo is going to plant a knight on f4
and i'm not going to have a fabulous
time
so i played knight f5 myself knight e6
and now i played bishop e3
if trades of course i will take with the
f pawn
i can't tolerate that knight
show up over there so bishop e3
g6 knight g3 queen h4
and you can tell that actually
duboff's plan was a success that
knight did arrive in a great position
and
it is heading towards d4 or f4
regarding and it's still kind of pending
or wherever
he wants to put that knight
so now again we've got a decision to
make
which side should we castle on
we can tell short castling does
not seem too appealing and eventually h5
might just wreck our position
so of course i went queen d2 bishop
takes
queen takes c3 i've got to otherwise the
knight is hanging
c5 now
there are problems with playing close
positions
if it's already quite bad but
luckily this situation is by no
means too bad
for white in fact if we can come up with
a good maneuver and find a good target
for white i might be able to turn this
position around
so our goal will be to find a good
outpost
for white species actually i did
the question is where is that outpost
yep the outpost is over here on d5
so i embarked on the mission of getting
there
if i get that spot i will
be standing quite well also knight e2
is multi-functional i take away
that knight f4 jump and i take away the
knight d4
jump in both cases i'd be ready to swap
off my knight
and black wouldn't be making any
progress
in that case b5
and i guess somewhat to his shock i
castled long
because i don't really fear b4 even if
we trade
i can just move my king back just walk
back to d
to e1 and my king is not
indirect danger pnf6
clearly threatening to go knight f4
the question is how do we react to this
idea of queen f6
well let me ignore it so i just go
and invent knight c3
and if knight f4 event knight d5
your threats are not real to me you
can't stick there i take your queen with
a check
take sticks and suddenly the position
starts shifting
i already castled his king is still in
the center
and i've got way more control in the
middle
than he does
so he realized that and goes for h6
so he's embarking on the mission of
closing everything down
so our job in this position will be
to undermine dubai's position
before he could consolidate
so it is white to move and undermine
black's position
so black clearly wants to play g5
because is somewhat afraid
of an f4 idea if
f4 according to my humble
math skills we're
going to lose a pawn in that case
definitely a wild
thought but maybe too brave
that when rookie one because i
kind of suspected that dubo is going to
play
g5 anyways stopping this f4 break
because
now f4 would be on the cards due to this
spin you cannot really castle
because f threats on queen h6 and after
g5
now as i see this weakening move
now i go d4 and
this is an offer he cannot refuse
i am going to be trading the pawn
she takes rook takes d4
and interestingly enough from a position
that was more like an e4e5 system
turns into a complete sicilian
stronghold position castles
okay so again dooboop survived this part
of the attack
so again we've got to do a restructuring
question which side should we play on
and
which targets can we latch on
from this position and in this case
there never really was a moment they
could trade
we had pressure on the e-file
b5 is weak i noticed that too
so i'll play rook b4 and not only
do i guard the f4 square
but i'm also setting up an idea
of undermining the b-pawn and if the
b-pawn falls
so is the a-pawn bishop d7
bishop f1 rook b8
and now my f1 bishop is
meeting the c2 charger pawn it's
all well charged it's very very
difficult for dubov
to do damage to this position because my
king is just
very well guarded there rook c8
but then my sicilian instincts kicked in
and i played king b1 just making sure
it does not run into danger
i was thinking about the idea of setting
up the
battery metallica style but it
does just feel like one single check
black can just move away with king f8
rook c5 rook d1
king f8
so i was very confident with my position
i think that white is better i still
think white is much better here
but being better does not mean
you're going to win
so we've got to come up with e a long
term plan
so if we looked at this position from a
strategical standpoint
which one of black's pieces are the best
or the most well coordinated
well one of them is the rook on c5
it defends and it attacks but there is
one other piece
that is sort of a nuisance and that's
the queen on f6
not only does it guard those squares but
it also
attacks my f2 pawn and is winking on my
king's side
i'm fairly confident that
my king is safe but you never know that
queen is lurking under the shadows and
anything can happen
so i played bishop e4 king e7
and i played queen e2 and i think
now you suspect what i'm attempting to
do here
because now it is blindingly obvious
we're doing the rook lift the rook
is showing up just to show the way
out for that lady
it's just being too much here we don't
want to hang around much longer
rook c4 he is willing to sacrifice upon
so i would not embark on this mission
but you can't stop me now
my rook is having a good time you can't
stop it at all
rook f3 and my rook is actually
unstoppable here
clean h8 and actually i'm trying to
go both ways i'm swinging at this one
and i'm swinging at the other one going
bishop d3
and i'm going after the b-pump so i'm
saying hey daniel go back
defend the b-pawn now rook b8
okay so so far so good
we've got a target on b5 we got a target
on f7
but we've got one more piece that is not
as heavily involved as it should be
the queen
how can we involve that queen a bit more
in this position
23. we're lurking in there yup
that is correct queen e3 and we
are lurking in there
now here duboff plays f6
but as we know f6
is a big no-no in ben's book
and if you're in ben's book you're in
trouble
f6 the queen is
cut out of action and
my pieces are just dominating
c3 over defending my pawns
you're going back you're going back
defending that
rook g3 and now duboff had enough
he knew i'm going to go h4 sooner or
later
so he is taking some desperate actions
and if they offer you a pawn you may as
well
not refuse it queen h6
bishop g6 f5
so now do above is trying to complicate
matters and then time on my rope so i
decided just to move it away
king f6 and now you can tell with the
king and queen
moving forward it is getting
more and more dire for daniel
so should we let our opponent go f4
or should we circumvent that with an
aggressive move
that is the big question here
now of course
we're not going to let f4 happen there
we're going to go queen e3 first
we go queen e3 first eyeing
that queen and that king and yet again
our villain of the day the queen is
arriving on a7
bishop e8
h4 undermining
the g pawn f4
and here i came up with
the decisive sequence so i'll give you a
chance
to find it this is a very very nice
sequence
and i hope you will find it as well
so currently i can't really take on g5
this queen takes g5 and
my queen is hanging as well so if takes
then pawn takes
and it's not abundantly clear what's
going to happen there
so instead here i have to reverse the
move orders
the question how i did that and also
notice if i move my queen there is
also this idea of taking on g6 with
check
and that is also on the cards
so wherever our queen moves you've got
to tan with bishop g6 and that's a big
question
if we have an idea against that
so let's say we move the queen there
what happens if they capture
the bishop
if you go queen e4 i take on g6
and if you take then this queen takes g5
and it's not going to be a lot of fun
so don't forget we are setting up this
idea of taking on g5
and threatening that so we've got a huge
threat
looming already
the big big threat looming
queen a7 bishop takes g6
and thank goodness chess
ain't no checkers you don't have to take
back on g6
i played king a1
and i'm down a piece
but black is basically out of moves
i'm threatening to take the rook
threatening to take the bishop
and i'm threatening to double attack
the king and queen
and after this very quiet move of king
a1
dubove has no way out queen f8
h takes g5 and a king has to walk
up in the center not a good sign
queen d7 check king e4
h takes g6 now i don't really want to
emphasize
king's safety here but my hunch tells me
that the king on a1 is slightly more
safe
than its counterpart on e4
and don't even get me started this is
not yet an
end game we still have the queen's rooks
on the board
and a real fight brewing in the center
a3 and i could try to react
on the queen side but i felt
it's much much better to push my jeep on
and create the additional threat of
promoting
queen c8 queen takes d6
he takes b2 king takes b2
and just picture this position the king
is basically without any shelter
the only pawns he has around are just
about to fall
to rookie one check
rook e8 check
king d3 queen takes e5
king d2 and queen e2
checkmate well
that king did go a long journey
just to end up checkmated on the d2
square
now dubove started off with a very
promising position
but once i managed to exchange off his
strong e6 knight
turn it around put pressure
on his weakened pawn structures i could
just get a very very
good grip on the position and then
go on with this beautiful sequence of
queen a7
and king a1 which was the key move there
yep that was quite a hike for that king
on d2
now this wasn't obviously a one-sided
match with daniel dubov so i want to
show you another game
that we played and
this one is quite pretty
you'll you'll see and it's quite a
masterful performance by
duboff okay so let's take a look
so d4 not d5
knight f3 and there is an interesting
story backstory for this one
so daniel dubov played
this variation c4 e5 which is called the
open
d takes e5 and knight e7
but if you check the databases carefully
enough
you will find a grand master
that the name of dennis borosch playing
this
around a handful and a dozens of times
i played this line myself
and you know just like anyone else i was
looking through
the magnus tour games and guess what i
see i see sam shankland
facing this knight e7 line the very line
i was popularizing played by daniel
dubov
so in comes this game daniel plays d4
d5 and he goes knight f3
he goes knight f3 and he is not
interested
if i want to play the albin variation
of the knight e7 one so interestingly
enough
whenever we got into this position this
is
what happened at f6
c4 e6
g3 bishop b4
check now here everybody
plays bishop to d2
and gets into a long theoretical line
but daniel dubov
doesn't like to go on the well trodden
path as we said
before he likes to go his own way
get something much more original i
castled
bishop g2 a5 castle
b6 knight e5 bishop b7
queen c2 knight d7 c takes d5
take take take knight f3
so here actually dubov already shows his
intentions
he is going aggressive he is willing to
double his pawns
but this pawn will also be of an asset
because it takes away this defensive
square from my knight
so his next threat is to go knight g5
and go directly attack my king so played
h6
just to stop that a3
bishop c5 rook d1
between c8 just sidestepping
this x-ray bishop d2
a4 knight t1 and 19 was a very very nice
move by daniel dubov
he is activating that knight
and tries to smoke out my bishop
and here i played bishop d4 which in
hindsight is somewhat inaccurate
i really should have tried to trade off
these bishops
and the position is more or less even in
this case
bishop d4 but bishop d4
actually allows a very nice little
tactical sequence
for daniel so let's try to find it
chat and viewers let's try to
find the move for adobo
same
so notice that this bishop on d4
is loose it's not defended and
it's vulnerable for tactical ideas
and in fact white
is able to go e4 here
put pressure on the d5 knight the knight
moves
and then takes on h6 with the marked
difference
if bishop f2 the queen can capture
and the queen will intrude in
black's position now of course i would
rather take on e5
but here white has this very surprising
idea of knight f3
going back and forth like a yo-yo
attacking that bishop it takes here this
is of course
strategically lost
and white obviously is better here now
he didn't play that he played knight d3
instead
giving the chance to go bishop a6 which
was a good move by me
because i have pressure on
the knight and the bishop takes e5 is
coming very soon
green takes a4 accepting that fact
bishop takes d3 takes
bishop takes e2 rook e1
c5 queen h4 bishop d3
and round round around here i felt very
content
with my position i have sort of a
pseudo karo khan situation i'm a move
away from chasing away
do above screen and i don't really think
that there's anything happening here
however after dubai's next move
there is a rude awakening happening
very rude awakening
bam bishop takes h6
the bishop arrives on h6
and i couldn't believe my eyes
do bob is giving up a whole piece with
my bishop guarding this ever so
important diagonal
takes queen takes h6
so i first had to realize what
the duboff's plan is duboff's plan is
clearly
to go bishop e4 trade
get to g4 and it's checkmate so let's
just say
b5 here takes takes
and rule g4 is deadly because if you
move the pawn
check here rook h formate
so actually attacking here is
much more intuitive than defending
but if you realize that one of the key
concepts
is to do this check so
get the screen g6 check there it's much
easier to
find this move of rook a7 i did not find
that one
because say bishop e4 takes
takes f5 black would be just in time to
go rogue g7
so rook a7 would have been an option
here
rook d1 bishop h7
bishop e4 f6 and of course
this whole variation continues on
but black is definitely
in play and probably is somewhat better
too
but rookies7 is not an easy move to find
because it is sort of four or five moves
deep
realizing that rook g7 is the way to
block off all those checks
also rook a7 does not have too much
connection
with this bishop and this bishop on d3
still seems very loose
so i came up with the idea of rook a4
which is also pretty
good i'm trying to take away and control
the fourth rank and stopping
any sort of bishop e4 or even rookie for
ideas
but daniel's next move is
again quite good in fact
quite amazing
what did do both play in this position
b4 indeed
just giving up upon all what he cares
about
is the initiative and this is sort of
the new more exciting way of playing
this game
of chess you are willing to take the
risks
but if your opponent
just misses just one beat
you're going to become a winner so
beaver is a very very nice move
and now suddenly bishop e4 is back on
the map
so i played bishop g6 so if bishop e4 i
can't go knight e7
membership g6 was a good move h4
c takes b4
and this is the moment where
he's sort of going overboard a little
bit
in this position white still
has enough play after bishop e4
black is still doing
very well but
white has play white definitely
has good play after take stakes h5
and with my king very much exposed
the pawn coming to e6
white is going to have enough play
more than that that is still up in the
air it's a very exciting position
but instead he goes h5 and h5
is not the most accurate way of playing
bishop f5 g4 but
talking about accurate i've been
defending well so far
and now we've got to decide what to do
should we go for a counter play or
should we
stick to our extra material advantage
and that's the question i had to answer
here as black
of course i can't really take that then
there would be queen g5s and they take
my bishop and i didn't want any part of
that
that one
so the truth is the move i played b3 was
a good move
but bishop c2 would have been safer
and after rookie 4 trades trades
the logical conclusion would be queen g6
and there's perpetual check so i went
for b3 which is a bit
more adventurous still good
but it turns out to be
a little bit too adventurous from my
part
and the next move is crucial
and here i make a slip which will cost
me dearly
i go rook g4 here which was a little bit
too early
the idea was correct this is the way to
defend against
any future checks and get counter play
on the king on g1
however on the other hand
b2 would have been the most accurate
move
rook d1 and now rook g4
now rook g4 is the move
and the only thing i really missed is
the fact that after rook
e4 black has this very unique
defensive idea of rook g7 f6
rook h7 and the king can hide on h8
and i don't know if you can call this
logical
i wouldn't dare this call this a logical
defense
the rook actually crabs its way back
to the king side from a8
from g4 to g7 to h7
that would have been quite a journey
now the best move here is f6
knight f4 and white
holds the equilibrium with this move of
king h1
and draw occurs after rook h4 check
here and rook g4 not at all
unfindable moves but that b2 move
would have been crucial
and b2 would have been crucial because
it oftentimes threatens to promote the
queen
in some specific lines but i played rook
g4
and rook g4 runs into
rook e4 now and with this pawn
just too far away and can't go here
because rook takes g4
i am just losing
he takes f5 takes
takes bishop d5 and now obviously it is
game over
b2 we played a couple more moves
but queen g6 is again a very nice
technical solution
he is double attacking and my king
is pinned so i can't take with the f
pawn
here here here here
and rook takes b2 so quite a beautiful
win
by daniel dubov so
i wanted to show that he did play a
magnificent game
but that is not all i've got a third
game for all of you probably
my favorite so let's take a look at this
one
again in this one i was white however in
this case
i actually played d4 instead of e4
knight f6 knight f3 e6
c4 c5 e3 a6
and funnily enough again dubov
doesn't feel like changing it up
d5 and here i was wondering
what i should do in this situation
and i realized well
dubo is going to take on c4 so i'm going
to go on id2
take here and centralize my knight
so takes b5
knight e5 bishop b7
but here dubo missed one critical thing
critical critical idea
which is seldom happening ever
in these games it's a very very rare
plan
i have knight g5 and suddenly
there's no way you can stop knight takes
f7
c4 obviously i take you can take my
bishop
because i take your queen bishop b4
bishop d2 queen a5
now in this position i'm already winning
but when you're winning try to go for
clarity and so i did
i went for knight d6 check knight takes
takes sticks
c takes f3 realize that dubo wants to go
on it4
i said no no no no don't want any part
of that
check king takes d3 again
there's no rook c8 because of knight d6
check
knight d5 rook c1 a4
trying to probe for more weaknesses
rook c8 king e2 no rook takes c6
tricourinos and b6
a5 b3 so if you take
i take on c4 and i'm going to cover up
everything that knight c5
so that's not an advantage for my
opponent so took
knight d6 rook c7
and here i realized something
my opponent's pieces are tangled up
so it's white to move and take advantage
of that
and this is probably the most unique
position i ever got in my chest career
so the first move is knight e4 check
if you move the king anywhere to g6 or
f7 i can check here take on c7 and i
win the knight on e3
so black has to oblige and go king f5
has to go king f5 there is
basically no other choice
however this is the beginning of the app
it's white to move and win
g4 check you can't really take that
because i check you and take the knight
so you've got to go deeper in the woods
knight e5 and
black's king is mated
on the middle of the board
if you go rook takes c1 well i
ain't going to take your rook it's
knight d3 checkmate
it's game over and
your king again wandered straight
in to the forest of pawns and knights
it's just being captured in the middle
of the board
quite quite a scene
so my opponent decided to take on g4 as
a desperado
i can check and i did checked again
king here i took on c7
takes rook g1 now i'm pinning
the piece f takes
check check and because
king e7 runs into knight g6 check
in this position daniel dubov resigned
so i really hope you enjoyed these
fascinating games
that i played against daniel dubov
hopefully
there'll be more to come i enjoyed it
very much
and some of these games felt
a little bit unusual even for me thank
you so much for watching
and good night
[Music]
you